breaking news, another mass
shooting in California.
This time of half moon bay.
About 28 miles south of San
Francisco.
Seven people killed in multiple
locations, at least one other
person is critically injured.
A suspect is in custody, and
San Mateo county sheriff's
office has identified him as 67
year old, June the Zhao, a half
moon bay residents.
They believe acted alone.
I want to bring in CNN's
Camilla Bernal for the very
latest.
Camilla, it's hard to believe
her talent at the shooting, the
Simon half moon bay.
We >> Know that it is one
shooter who went to multiple
locations, this happened at
around 2:22 local time this
afternoon.
We were told that the suspect
went to the first location and
shot five people, for them
killed that location, one of
them critically injured.
Then he went to another
location about a mile that
killed another three people.
We've been told this is a
mushroom farm, the people call
it a nursery, and general, it
is an agricultural area.
And police had not made an
arrest until about 4:30 in the
afternoon.
That is when the suspect was
spotted at the sheriff
substation.
Now, we know that it was a
plainclothes officer who saw
the suspect, who saw the Carter
looking for, and speaking to my
colleague Josh Campbell who
pointed out this was not the
massive swat team operation
that we saw and southern
California.
This was an officer who you see
there wearing a tie.
And taking this man down, and
arresting him, but Josh
Campbell pointing out that they
did not see cover.
They were not hiding behind
cars.
Instead, they thought this was
no boards to make at the
moment.
We know he was taken into
custody, they were covered a
semiautomatic handgun.
After this arrest.
We know he is cooperating with
authorities.
The Dea team is interviewing
that suspect at the moment.
But we know he acted alone.
Authorities say there is no
threat to the community.
Yet they have not given us a
motive.
They're working on it, but so
far they say they do not know
why this happened.
>> Did anything about him in
particular?
We have is H, the picture,
women about him particular?
>> We know is a half moon bay
resident.
Authorities believe that he was
an employee --
so they believe that the people
he killed were also employees
in this area.
Again, 67-year-old resident of
half moon bay.
He is, in custody.
Authorities are speaking to him
at the moment.
Hopefully we get more clarity
on why he did that.
>> And mark Berman of
California's 23rd district.
Such a tragedy.
It is unbelievable to think
about the pacing of such
tragedies.
Hauser community grappling with
us tonight?
>> The shock in disbelief.
This happened and half moon bay,
such an idyllic part of San
Mateo county.
I'll tell you, at 2:22, just
before 2:22.
At the California state
capitals my colleagues.
--
and then I had to midway over
to the office and see on social
media that there was a mass
shooting in my district.
So I the communities are scared
and we have to see how to
support them tonight of, days
weeks, months ahead.
>> No one ever thinks is going
to happen and their hometown.
With the rise, and prevalence
of gun violence in this
country.
As your community developed and
law enforcement collectively.
I am in the kind of cases were
to happen.
Don't have to just a cold
reality.
>> We're very fortunate, 70
catches on the best one
counties in the state.
And we saw on the video, you
know, remarkably professional
chefs apartment that covers
half moon bay, and covers the
cosign of San Mateo county.
And they're able to --
without any more death to
anyone else.
But, I had a couple of school
classes up in the capitol last
year.
And when I asked them, what is
one thing that you would like
to change in your community
there are two different groups.
And the first group, these are
fourth grade students,
ten-year-olds.
The first group, the first
thing they said, there's no
more shootings and schools.
The second, group the third
thing they said was no more
shootings in schools.
I wasn't dreaming of that
nightmare when I was a
ten-year-old.
And so it unfortunately has a
really permeated every aspect
of society, and we need to do
more to protect our
communities.
>> Talk about children I have
ten-year, old eight-year-old,
who know that part of the
school day and some part during
the year had to tail what we
use have as a fire drill.
They had have active shooter
training, or kind of response.
It really is unnerving to say
the very least.
They are substantial John, at
the scene, this is not out of
school.
What did about the presence of
children at the shooting scene?
>> It was farmworker housing.
And there are lot of farming,
and agriculture on the coast.
And farmworker housing.
With all family lives.
We're people in the family may
work on the farm worthless,
including children were there.
It is tragic, it is tragic to
think and we're still learning
details about the victims.
We can also soon that mothers,
fathers, sons, daughters, were
killed far too soon.
And the fact that their own
pharmacies were nearby.
This makes it that much worse.
It is really a senseless gun
violence that we have in the
United States that is so deep
from anywhere else in the
country.
>> Do you happen to know why
they believe this is targeted?
I know you have this motive, it
is precise motive?
Were there any indications to
what they thought was targeted?
>> I don't know yet, to be
honest, but I'm sure that will
come out soon.
But I don't know.
>> We will have to see what is
happening as this all unfolds.
I'm just thinking about it, as
you said, being on the capitol,
just honoring as a visual the
loss of life in another
community.
Only to have it happen right at
your front door.
Thank you so much, thank you
for your community.
>> Thanks so much, Laura.
I wanna bring in former FBI
deputy director, and duplicate
and retired LAPD sergeant,
Cheryl Dorsey is with us as
well.
A lot happening as we get the
information in a truly is
unfolding.
I will begin with you, sergeant
Dorsey, because you've got to
mask shootings.
Days apart, and California.
Monterey park was one, now half
moon bay.
Why has this become so common.
Do you think as my colleague
earlier spoke about, Charles
Ramsey.
That there is a fear that
people might be coming
desensitize to what has been
happening.
>> I think we are already
there.
I wonder the insensitive
shooting, it half moon bay,
this is like a copycat.
Obviously, there's a lot of
press about what happened in
Monterrey California.
It was an Asian man who
victimize other agents.
Now we have something similar
and northern California.
Is someone who's been's doing
and brewing and had a hiked
over an issue and decided, you
know what?
I'm going to do that very thing
that we just heard about in
southern California.
Sometimes, there's a reason why
the news puts information out
there.
I wonder if we really need to
know every single thing that
occurs.
>> That's an important points.
And our colleague of mine,
Shannon, was speaking about
this.
The idea of not immediately
discounting the possibility of
hate crimes.
Simply because the person is of
the same race of some of the
victims.
There could be the same type of
animus, gender, wise or
otherwise wise, and beyond,
that can't be discounted.
But sergeant Dorsey's point.
The availability of
information.
The need for transparency, at
least in the court of public
opinion.
Do you think that can, at times,
way against the ability to stop
crimes like this?
I >> That is hard to say, it is
totally understandable that
communities are looking for
answers to questions like, what
motivated this person to commit
this horrible act?
It is a way of understanding,
or assessing future danger.
Is there something else out
there that we should be worried
about?
We want to kind of, be able to
categorize these things in our
mind and put them into a
particular box in terms of the
way that we understand them.
And so, the thirst for
inspiration, to understand
things like motive, intent, is
really never-ending.
However, at least it is sort of
coverage that we're doing right
now, that we did over the
weekend, that we always do
around these events.
That, could in fact serve to
draw more attention to these
individuals, and so the methods,
and to their equipment, and
their guns, and everything
else.
It is really hard, or in a very
top spot in terms of trying to
bring people the information
they reasonably seek.